will the house be in order
the tellers agree in their tallies that
the total number of votes casts is 433.
of which The Honorable Hakeem Jeffries
of the state of New York has received
212.
thank you
The Honorable Kevin McCarthy of the
State of California has received 201
[Applause]
0 The Honorable Byron Donalds of the
State of Florida has received 20.
[Applause]
with one recorded as present
[Applause]
no member elect haven't received a
majority of the votes cast a speaker has
not been elected
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from Florida rise
thank you madam clerk I rise today to
nominate Kevin McCarthy as Speaker of
the people's house
[Music]
the gentlewoman is recognized
foreign
my colleagues
well it's Groundhog Day
again you
I would like to
will the house be in order thank you
madam clerk if it's all right with you
all I would like to address not you but
the American people because quite
frankly
they are
foreign
speaker yet
so
the American people well they are our
boss and we work for them
yesterday as we were here on the house
floor our constituents from all around
the country made their voices heard
today the calls the text messages emails
they all continue people are letting
their voice be heard and that is a very
very good thing
[Applause]
because that is what we are after all a
constitutional republic that serves all
Americans not just a select few
to all Americans watching right now I
want to tell you that we hear you
we hear you
and we will get this right no matter how
messy this process is we will emerge
better for having been through this
because nothing great ever comes easy
for the last several months negotiations
have gone back and forth over a rules
package to make this chamber your
chamber
a better place to deliver better results
for you
the American people and I want to remind
everyone
watching listening here in this chamber
that this chamber
and this body
our country
we are bigger than a single person or a
single moment in time we are a nation
collectively of great people great
Patriots and great moments of Courage
the rules package that has been
highlighted
by so many of my colleagues dictates how
this chamber functions how bills come to
the floor how much time we get to read
these bills whether or not we will get
single issue bills and whether or not we
can vote proxy
and as you have witnessed from events
yesterday so many people have said what
are the next steps what will we
accomplish if we continue down this
current path
will we wake up tomorrow and be in this
exact same place
the people calling my office said over
and over and over again it is time to
get to work
anything less is unacceptable
and you know
as we stood on this house floor
yesterday and again today
over 200 people were poisoned from
fentanyl fentanyl that came from an open
border because of the Biden open border
policy
over five thousand people were
encountered at the border because of
Biden's open border policies
these are the issues that people care
about
they don't sit around their kitchen
tables at night saying I wonder who's
going to be speaker no they elect people
to come here to do the things that
matter
the issues that impact them every single
day and in an era of uncertainty
the last thing they need is uncertainty
within this chamber
we were elected to be the voice of our
constituents
we are their voice in this chamber
and they didn't send us to be Perpetual
critics they sent us
to get things done
[Applause]
and as we all know
because after all we are in politics
the line of critics is always long but
the list of those that are actually
rolling up their sleeves and doing the
difficult job of leading of uniting of
delivering results especially in a
chamber like this well that list is very
short
Kevin McCarthy has proved
that he can get things done he has
proven that he is willing to stand up in
the face of critics
and not only prove them wrong but work
with them
the only thing Sovereign in this
Republic are its people
and they have deemed it right to place a
check on the Biden Administration
and put our party
the Republican party in control of this
chamber now is the time that we take
control
I understand a lack of trust among some
of our colleagues I do
be an order
I understand a lack of trust among some
of our colleagues
but what I am asking
what I am asking is that we all
trust the American people
who sent our colleagues here
this house is the only part of the
federal government that stands for
election every two years therefore this
chamber is an instrument of the people's
will and the people have overwhelmingly
voted for Kevin McCarthy
foreign
if we continue down this road if we
continue
with the actions of yesterday and today
we stifle the will of the American
people
the changes to the rules
of this place and how it functions have
been overwhelmingly positive in the last
few weeks legislation stands ready it is
time to unite roll up our sleeves and
get to work doing the people's business
a gentleman my friend Kevin McCarthy
from California has done more
than anyone in this chamber to secure a
republican majority
many of the people who are members here
today are quite frankly here because of
his leadership
because they have trusted him
and he has gone out of his way to make
sure that every single one of us has had
a voice at the table
furthermore every single returning
Republican in this chamber
who cast a vote two years ago in the
last Congress voted for Kevin McCarthy
as our leader
we were United then
and we must unify now
that's the only way to start the
people's business the very reason that
we're all here
it's to unify
and get to work
because we must commit to Unity instead
of division because we owe it to the
American people who sent us here we must
choose to lead in the face of a liberal
Senate and Obama's JV team in the White
House
we owe it to the American people
the American people sent a conservative
majority to govern this body but we
cannot even begin to govern because heck
we can't even swear in as members of
Congress
I've traveled the country for the last
two years as the youngest Republican
woman in the 117th Congress helping to
secure a majority of members who are on
both sides of today's Republican vote
diversity of thought is a good thing
it's one of the things that sets us
apart from our friends on the other side
of the aisle yes diversity of thought is
a good thing
but they want us divided they want us to
fight each other that much has been made
clear by the popcorn and blankets and
alcohol that is coming over there
the house is not in order
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the house is not in order
[Applause]
[Music]
the clerk would ask all members elect to
abide by the established decorum of the
house while making nominations
[Music]
gentlewoman is recognized
yeah
as evidenced by my colleague's actions
so today I am asking
my friends and colleagues are we the
party of Reagan Republicans
Reagan who said
someone who is with me eighty percent of
the time is a loyal and good friend not
a 20 Trader
are we the party of Reagan
that is the question that I ask you to
answer as we embark on this next ballot
it's a it's upon us
to remain a nation of equal opportunity
not equal outcome that is what is on the
line here today and that is why I am
nominating Kevin McCarthy and I humbly
ask for your support Madam Clerk I yield
back
yourself
foreign
for what purpose does a gentleman from
California rise
Madam clerk I Rise to nominate Hakeem
Jeffries as Speaker of the House the
lead vote getter in the final in the
last five rounds the gentleman is
recognized
foreign
clerk Democrats are united behind a
speaker who will build safer communities
he's a leader in gun violence prevention
he has worked to make our Criminal
Justice System more fair more Equitable
and more effective and he's done it
working with both sides of the aisle a
leader who has a track record in
actually getting things done
and he understands that Public Safety
public health and Economic Opportunity
must go hand in hand that's why at the
direction of the democratic caucus I
Advance the name of Hakeem Jeffries from
Brooklyn New York as our next speaker
for the 118th Congress
thank you
for what purpose does a gentleman from
Pennsylvania rise
Madam speaker to nominate the
gentleman from Florida Mr Donalds the
gentleman is recognized thank you
ladies and gentlemen
no matter what side of the aisle you're
on no matter what your political
persuasion one thing is universally
recognized across this country
Washington is broken
Washington is completely broken whether
it's a wide open border millions of
people streaming across terrorists
criminals fentanyl coming right to your
community not at the border but into
your community
overdoses
happening in your towns funerals
happening in your town because the
borders open because this place is
broken
12 days ago
in the middle of the night 4 000 Pages
showed up over here set six and a half
or two at 2.7 Trill 1.7 sorry 1.7
trillion dollars in spending
seven seventy two hundred ear marks 24
hours time to read it like a Christmas
tree right before Christmas that nobody
outside of this town wanted
if you've been here for one year you
voted on that once if you've been here
for three years you voted on the same
thing three times if you've been here
for 10 years
you voted on it 10 times Washington is
broken
we got crime running across the streets
no matter what community you're in
because now this town has decided that
somehow the criminals aren't understood
and we've abandoned the victims
this is what people in our country are
dealing with we are funding Wars in
other countries while we're destroying
our own military because this town is
broken
we have an Administration that has
contempt for the American people and is
using these big corporations that spy on
Americans
and using the instruments of federal
power to persecute and prosecute them
because this town is broken and this
place is literally broken there hasn't
been an amendment on the floor for six
years in this town
so if you're not on the committee of
jurisdiction but it affects your
citizens well too bad for you you just
vote Yes or you just vote no that's not
how this place was designed to be
we vote on bills that have all kinds of
things that have nothing to do with the
bill itself
everybody came here because they said to
their constituents this town is broken
and I want to fix it
well how are you going to fix it if you
come to this town and just step right in
line and keep doing the same things that
everybody has done before you
it's not going to fix it and the
American people know it
and I would say this
I think the person that has done the
most
that has done the most to make this
fabulous
this wonderful Republican majority
is Speaker Pelosi and her policies
that's what has achieved this majority
over here because the American people
are sick and tired of it and they've had
enough of it
now this is not about
this is not about personalities
it's not about personalities
it's about the policies that come out of
here this is not about personalities on
this side of the aisle or that side of
the aisle we believe and we want to
believe
Burger Gardens
We Believe
and we want to believe that every person
that comes here Left Right Center has
the best intentions for our country
the best intentions for our country and
it's not about the Personalities in this
contest
it is not personal for us
but because we all acknowledge and we
all know
that Washington is broken we must take A
New Path
there must be a new vision
so that Congress
works for the American people
because the American people are watching
what's happening here and they've
watched what's happened here and they're
sure in their hearts and they can prove
it
that this town works for this town
that's who this town is working for
ladies and gentlemen
we are making history today we are
making history in this process
and we are showing the American people
that this process works yeah it's been
about a hundred years
it's been about a hundred years
since this has happened before but we
have said we are not going to take any
more of Washington being broken we're
going to do something for the American
people and we're going to fix it and is
it going to be painful and is it going
to be difficult yeah it probably is
that's why it took 100 years
it probably is but we're going to do it
and we can also make history today
by making the first
[Music]
the house being ordered by electing the
first
black Republican Speaker of the House
yes thank you
now as my colleagues probably know the
first black members of Congress to serve
in this body were Republicans
were Republicans
as a matter of fact you probably also
know that Frederick Douglass
who went and worked with Abraham Lincoln
to emancipate the people of color in
this country said he would never be
anything but a republican would never be
anything but a Republican
I am here to nominate Byron Donalds
because he has accomplished many things
he is a man of faith
he is a family man he is a businessman
and he is a man of community service
he's come from the School of Hard Knocks
because not all outcomes in life are
equal but America is the place where we
can each do great things regardless of
our humble beginnings each one of us
now Byron is product of single family
where it's not easy it's not easy
but he has succeeded in America and
that's a testament to what we have
created here and what we're trying to
save he's got a record of accomplishing
things he has a record of being on the
right side he is respected he is trusted
he is capable and he achieves results
now Byron has a big mind and he's big in
stature as well he's very nice but I
will tell you this in a negotiation
in the negotiation with Chuck Schumer I
should want to be on the other side of
Byron Donald's he knows who he is he
knows what his foundation is and he
knows that Washington is broken and what
Chuck Schumer sends over here
is it going to work out for the American
people
ladies and gentlemen
Washington is broken
Byron Donald's
will inspire us and restore our citizens
faith that this institution actually
works for them and it is my highest
honor to nominate the gentleman from
Florida Byron Donalds to be the next
Speaker of the House in ideal
[Applause]
the reading clerk will call the roll
Adams
Jeffries
aderholt
McCarthy
Aguilar
Jeffries
offered
McCarthy
Allen
McCarthy
Allred
Jeffries
amode
McCarthy
Armstrong
McCarthy
Arrington
McCarthy
akinclass
Jeffries
Babin
McCarthy
bacon
McCarthy
Baird
McCarthy
balderson
McCarthy
balance
Jeffries
thanks
McCarthy
Barr
McCarthy
better gone
Jeffries
being of Florida
McCarthy
baby
Jeffries
fence
McCarthy
bear
Jeffries
Bergman
Bergman
fire
Jeffries
spice
McCarthy
Biggs
Donald's
villarakis
McCarthy
Bishop of Georgia
Jeffries
Bishop of North Carolina
Donald's
blumenauer
Jeffrey's
blunt Rochester
Jeffries
bobert
Donald's
bonamichi
Jeffries
vast
McCarthy
Bowman
Jeffries
Boyle of Pennsylvania
Jeffries
breaking
Donald's
Brown
Jeffrey's
Brownlee Jeffries
Buchanan
McCarthy
buck
Bouchon
McCarthy
butzinski
Jeffries
Birch it
McCarthy
Burgess
McCarthy
Burleson
McCarthy
bush
Jeffries
Calvert
McCarthy
kamik
McCarthy
caraveo
Jeffries
carbajal
Jeffries
Cardenas
Jeffries
Carrie
McCarthy
Carl
McCarthy
Carson
Jeffries
Carter of Georgia
McCarthy
Carter of Louisiana
Jeffries
Carter of Texas
McCarthy
Cartwright
Jeffries
kasar
Jeffries
case
Jeffrey's
Caston
Jeffries
Castor of Florida
Jeffries
Castro of Texas
Jeffries
Chavez derimer
McCarthy
McCormick
Jeffries
chew
Jeffries
sicilini
Jeffries
Cisco Mani
McCarthy
Clark of Massachusetts
Clark of New York
Jeffries
Cleaver
Jeffries
Klein
McCarthy
cloud
Donald's
Clyburn
Jeffries
Clyde
Donald's
Cohen
Jeffries
Cole
McCarthy
Collins
McCarthy
Comer
McCarthy
Connolly
Jeffries
Korea
Jeffries
Costa
Jeffries
Courtney
Jeffries
Craig
Jeffries
crane
Donald's
Crawford
McCarthy
Crenshaw
McCarthy
Crockett
Jeffries
Crow
Jeffries
Cuellar
Jeffries
Curtis
McCarthy
David's of Kansas
Jeffries
Davidson
McCarthy
Davis of Illinois
Jeffries
Davis of North Carolina Jeffries
dean of Pennsylvania
Jeffrey's
to get
Jeffrey's
De La Cruz
McCarthy
delauro
Jeffries
Del Bene
Jeffries
delusio
Jeffries
dasanier
Jeffries
dejalay
McCarthy
di Esposito
McCarthy
Diaz ballart
McCarthy
Dingle
Jeffries
Doggett
Jeffrey's
Donald's
Donald's
[Applause]
Duarte
McCarthy
Duncan
McCarthy
Dunn of Florida
McCarthy
Edwards
McCarthy
Elsie
McCarthy
emmer
McCarthy
Escobar
Jeffries
SU
Jeffrey's
espayat
Jeffries
Estes
McCarthy
Evans
Jeffries
ezel
McCarthy
Fallon
McCarthy
finstra
McCarthy
Ferguson
McCarthy
finstad
McCarthy
fishbach
McCarthy
Fitzgerald
McCarthy
Fitzpatrick
McCarthy
Fleischmann
McCarthy
Fletcher
Jeffries
flood
McCarthy
Foster
Jeffries
fushi
Jeffries
Fox
McCarthy
Lois Frankel
Jeffries
see Scott Franklin
McCarthy
Frost
Jeffries
fry
McCarthy
Fulcher
McCarthy
Gates
Donald's
Gallagher
McCarthy
Gallego
Gallego
Jeffries
Garamendi
Jeffries
garberino
McCarthy
Mike Garcia
McCarthy
Robert Garcia
Jeffries
Garcia of Illinois
Jeffries
Garcia of Texas
Jeffries
Jimenez
McCarthy
golden of Maine
Jeffries
Goldman of New York
Jeffries
Gomez
Jeffries Jeffries
Tony Gonzalez
McCarthy
Vicente Gonzalez
Jeffries
good of Virginia
Donald's
Gooden of Texas
McCarthy
Go star
Donald's
got timer
Jeffries
Granger
McCarthy
Graves of Louisiana
Graves of Louisiana
McCarthy
Graves of Missouri
McCarthy
green of Tennessee
McCarthy
green of Texas
[Music]
Jeffries
green of Georgia
McCarthy
Griffith
McCarthy
Grijalva
Jeffries
growthman
McCarthy
guest
McCarthy
Guthrie
McCarthy
Hagerman
McCarthy
harder of California
Jeffries
Harris
Donald's
harshbarger
McCarthy
Hayes
Jeffries
Hearn
McCarthy
Higgins of Louisiana
McCarthy
Higgins of New York
Jeffrey's
Hill
McCarthy
Hines
Jeffries
Henson
McCarthy
horseford
Jeffrey's
Houchin
McCarthy
Houlihan
Jeffries
Hoyer
Jeffries
Hoyle of Oregon
Jeffries
Hudson
McCarthy
Huffman
suggestions Jeffries
huizinga
McCarthy
hunt
McCarthy
Isa
Isa
McCarthy
ivy
Jeffries
Jackson of Illinois
Jeffries
Jackson of North Carolina
Jeffries
Jackson of Texas
McCarthy
Jackson Lee
Jeffries
Jacobs
Jeffries
James
McCarthy
jail Paul
Jeffries
Jeffries
Jeffries
[Applause]
Johnson of Georgia
Jeffries
Johnson of Louisiana
McCarthy
Johnson of Ohio
McCarthy
Johnson of South Dakota
McCarthy
Jordan
McCarthy
Joyce of Ohio
McCarthy
Joyce of Pennsylvania
McCarthy
Kim lager dove
Jeffries
Captor
Jeffrey's
Kane of New Jersey
McCarthy
Keating
Jeffries
Kelly of Illinois
Jeffries
Kelly of Mississippi
McCarthy
Kelly of Pennsylvania
McCarthy
Kana
Jeffries
kiggins of Virginia
McCarthy
kildee
Jeffries
Kylie
McCarthy
Kilmer
Jeffries
Kim of California
McCarthy
Kim of New Jersey
Jeffries
krishnamurthy
Jeffries
Custer
Jeffries
kustoff
McCarthy
lahood
McCarthy
lalota
McCarthy
la malpha
McCarthy
Lamborn
McCarthy
landsman
Jeffries
Langworthy
McCarthy
Larson of Washington
Jeffries
Larson of Connecticut
Jeffries
Lada
McCarthy
letourner
McCarthy
Lawler
McCarthy
Lee of California
Jeffries
Lee of Florida
Lee of Florida
McCarthy
Lee of Nevada
Jeffries
Lee of Pennsylvania
Jeffries
Ledger Fernandez
Jeffries
lesko
McCarthy
let low
McCarthy
Levin
Jeffries
Lou
Jeffrey's
Lofgren
Jeffries
Loudermilk
McCarthy
Lucas
McCarthy
Luke cameyer
McCarthy
Luna
Luna
Donald's
Latrell
McCarthy
Lynch
Jeffries
mace
McCarthy
magazineer
magazineer
maliotakis
McCarthy
man
McCarthy
Manning
Jeffries
Massey
McCarthy
Mass
McCarthy
Matsui
Jeffries
Macbeth
Jeffries
McCarthy
McCarthy
[Applause]
McCall
McCarthy
McLean
McCarthy
McClintock
McCarthy
McCullum
Jeffries
McCormick
McCarthy
McGovern
Jeffries
McGarvey
Jeffries
McHenry
McHenry
McCarthy
Meeks
Jeffries
Menendez
Jeffries
mang
Jeffries
muser
McCarthy
ome
Jeffries
Miller of Illinois
Donald's
Miller of Ohio
Miller of Ohio
Miller of West Virginia
McCarthy
Miller Meeks
McCarthy
Mills
McCarthy
molinero
McCarthy
molinar
McCarthy
Mooney
McCarthy
Moore of Alabama
McCarthy
Moore of Utah
McCarthy
more of Wisconsin
Jeffries
Moran
McCarthy
Morelli
Jeffries
Moskowitz
Jeffries
Moulton
Jeffries
mervan
Jeffrey's
Mullen
Jeffries
Murphy
McCarthy
Nadler
Jeffries
Napolitano
Jeffries
Neil
Jeffries
negus
Jeffrey's
nails
McCarthy
new house
McCarthy
nickel
Jeffries
Norcross
Jeffries
Norman
Donald's
none of Iowa
McCarthy
obernauti
McCarthy
ocasio-cortez
Jeffries
hogles
Donald's
Omar
Jeffrey's
Owens
McCarthy
pallone
Jeffries
Palmer
McCarthy
Panetta
Jeffries
Pappas
Jeffries
pasquerel
Jeffries
pain
Jeffries
Pelosi
Jeffries
peltola
Jeffries
Pence
McCarthy
Perez
Jeffries
Perry
Donald's
foreign
Jefferson
Patterson
Jeffries
fluger
McCarthy
Phillips
Jeffries
Pingree
Jeffrey's
pocan
Jeffrey's
Porter
Jeffries
Posey
McCarthy
Presley
Jeffries
Quigley
Jeffries
Ramirez
Jeffries
Raskin
Jeffries
russianthaler
McCarthy
Rogers of Washington
McCarthy
Rogers of Alabama
McCarthy
Rogers of Kentucky
McCarthy
Rose
McCarthy
Rosendale
Donalds
Ross
Jeffries
Rouser
McCarthy
Roy
Donald's
Ruiz
Jeffries
ruppersberger
Jeffries
Rutherford
McCarthy
Ryan
Jeffries
Salazar
Salazar
McCarthy
McCarthy
Salinas
Jeffries
Sanchez
Jeffries
Santos
McCarthy
sarbanes
Jeffrey's
scalise
McCarthy
Scanlan
Jeffries
shakowski
Jeffries
Schiff
Jeffrey's
Schneider
Jeffries
skolton
Jeffries
schreier
Jeffrey's
Schweikert
McCarthy
Scott
Austin Scott
McCarthy
David Scott
Jeffries
Scott of Virginia
Jeffries
self
Donald's
sessions
McCarthy
Sewell
Jeffries
Sherman
Jeffries
Cheryl
Cheryl
Simpson
McCarthy
slotkin
Jeffrey's
Smith of Missouri
Smith of Missouri
Smith of Nebraska
McCarthy
Smith of New Jersey
McCarthy
Smith of Washington
Jeffries
smucker
McCarthy
Sorensen
Jeffries
Soto
Jeffries
spanberger
Jeffries
Sparks
Sparks
Sansbury
Stansbury
Jeffrey's
Stanton
Jeffries
stauber
McCarthy
Steel
McCarthy
symphonic
McCarthy
Style
McCarthy
stewby
McCarthy
Stevens
Jeffries
Stewart
McCarthy
Strickland
Jeffries
strong
McCarthy
swalwell
Jeffries
Sykes
Jeffries
takano
takano
Jeffries
tinny
tinny
McCarthy
tanadar
Jeffries
Thompson of California
Jeffries
Thompson of Mississippi
Jeffries
Thompson of Pennsylvania
McCarthy
Tiffany
McCarthy
Timmins
McCarthy
Titus
Jeffries
Talib
Jeffries
takuda
Jeffries
tonko
Jeffries
Torres of California
Jeffries
Torres of New York
Jeffries
Trahan
Jeffries
trone
Jeffries
Turner
Turner
McCarthy
Underwood
Jeffries
valadeo
McCarthy
van Drew
McCarthy
Van Dyne
McCarthy
Van Orden
McCarthy
Vargas
Jeffries
Vasquez
Jeffries
VC
Jeffries
Velazquez
Jeffries
Wagner
McCarthy
Wahlberg
McCarthy
Waltz
Waltz
Wasserman Schultz
Jeffrey's
Waters
Jeffries
Watson Coleman
Jeffries
Weber of Texas
McCarthy
Webster of Florida
McCarthy
winstrup
McCarthy
Westerman
McCarthy
wexton
Jeffries
Wild
Jeffries
Williams of Georgia
Jeffries
Williams of New York
McCarthy
Williams of Texas
McCarthy
Wilson of Florida
Jeffries
Wilson of South Carolina
McCarthy
Whitman
McCarthy
Womack
McCarthy
Jacob
McCarthy
Zinky
McCarthy
the reading clerk will now call the
names of the members elect who did not
answer the first call of the roles
Bergman
McCarthy
buck
ET McCarthy
okay
yeah
magazineer
Jeffries
Miller of Ohio
McCarthy
Cheryl
Jeffries
Smith of Missouri
McCarthy
Sparks
present
Waltz
McCarthy
thank you
foreign
thank you
thank you
the tellers agree in their tallies that
the total number of votes cast is 433.
of which The Honorable Hakeem Jeffries
of the state of New York has received
212.
foreign
[Applause]
The Honorable Kevin McCarthy of the
State of California has received 201
[Applause]
The Honorable Baron Donalds of the State
of Florida has received 20.
foreign
member as present
no member elect haven't received the
majority of the votes cast a speaker has
not been elected
for what purpose does a gentleman from
Oklahoma rise I move that we adjourn
until eight o'clock this evening
the question is on the motion to adjourn
all those in favor say aye
aye
all those opposed no
[Applause]
eyes have it
the motion is adopted
as a member of the man in the A's and
A's
is a member demanding the A's and A's
okay motion is adopted the motion is
adopted
the house stands adjourned until 8 pm
tonight
thank you